thanks for being with us America Ben is
with us in Kansas City
I've been how are you doing great Dave
how are you better than I deserve
what's up hey it's an honor to speak
with you sir but I I've been considering
leading a Financial Peace University
course as a coordinator but I've got a
little bit of a moral dilemma
I guess I'm actually an independent
insurance agent and so I don't want the
students to get the wrong impression
that I may be coordinating it for the
wrong reasons
mm-hmm if you're not coordinating it for
the wrong reasons if you're not in there
sharking them then we're not gonna worry
about it
okay all right I guess that really
answers my question I just wanted to get
your take on it
I feel like I am doing it for the right
reasons I just I want to make sure they
get the most out of the class that they
can because it made a huge difference in
my life yeah for myself and my family so
I mean you could go to the extreme and
just say if you wanted to be super safe
and just go I'm not doing transactions
with any of you under any circumstances
okay that would be an extreme version
okay well the other version in the
middle would be you just don't bring it
up but if one of them asks you and comes
towards you and you want to serve them
by selling them then you know that's not
certainly not immoral or illegal or
anything like that it's you and I both
have been slimed we've both been in a
situation where somebody's doing stuff
for the wrong reasons we call that
transactional rather than relational
right correct they're there for what
they can get rather than what they can
give we all know that spirit you know it
or you wouldn't be concerned about it
you're not that guy or you wouldn't have
even asked the question right that's why
I'm not worried about you so I think
you'll be great at it I think you've got
a good heart because the guy that's that
guy wouldn't even ask this question
woody good point yeah and so I think
you're I think your your people in your
class will smell the spirit it will fit
since the spirit of you and go this
guy's not he's not a slime huh he's just
here and you'll probably end up a couple
of me may be able to help him if he said
you're in
you probably shop around help them get a
better dealings some of the P and C but
they'll probably bring it up to you and
you won't even have to talk about it and
but if you want to be just extreme about
it just go you know in order to avoid
that I'm just not going to none of you
can be my clients while you're in the
class you know you're later maybe or
something like that I'll tell you an
example of what I have done in that
situation God has blessed me with an
inordinately large income over the years
I mean when I started I was making
nothing but I started moving we've made
a lot of money helping millions and
millions of people and we've made me and
some millions of dollars doing it I mean
God has blessed me and so years ago when
I first started I really felt like God
whispering to me and saying when you
speak in a church don't get paid that
way you're not in church for the wrong
reason you're not seeing all the
churches as an opportunity serving God
in the church on Sunday as an
opportunity to to fleece the Sheep you
know it's not you're not there to do
that so I have never gotten paid on
Sunday morning for speaking at a church
ever and in 30 years of doing this and
you know back when I used to do actual
speaking events for money I don't hardly
ever do that anymore most of our
speaking events or stuff we do there are
our events and our ticketed and that
kind of thing
but back then I mean we were charged a
lot for me to go show up and and you
know speak somewhere but not on Sunday
morning and if a church tries to write
me a check I just have them direct it to
one of the one of the ministries that
that we support and they can send making
off you know make a donation to them if
they want to or just don't pay me but I
can't take money I'm prohibited from
taking money on Sunday morning by myself
by my own prohibition you see what I'm
saying so that's kind of the same thing
because I just didn't want to be that
guy and I think God was telling me not
to be that guy and that's not to say
somebody's wrong for getting paid to
speak in a church I mean pastors get
paid it's their job
to speak in churches and they should get
paid and they should get paid well and
if some of you were evangelists and you
get paid from going to different
churches and there's nothing wrong with
that and other people get paid in
churches and I got friends that the
Christian speakers and they get pain
churches that's all okay I'm not saying
anything wrong with you I just think for
me apparently because it's the money
subject and because well God blesses me
and the other six days a week so
unbelievably over-the-top that God just
said don't do that okay I can do that I
can stick with that so you can you can
set yourself some boundaries along those
lines but then you're gonna be fine
you're the good you're good you're the
good people and that that you're gonna
be fine and thank you for offering to
lead a Financial Peace University class
we're gonna be honored to have you